capri bryant honors her late sister
gianna bryant
in the cutest way the two-year-old
daughter of vanessa bryant and the late
kobe bryant
attended the wnba game on wednesday
showing up to the event
in gigi's basketball jersey prior to
kobe and gigi's tragic deaths from a
helicopter crash in january 2020
gigi was on her way to becoming a
basketball superstar
in her own right following in the
footsteps of her legendary los angeles
lakers star dad
gianna's pretty pretty easy to coach she
sported the number two jersey for the
mamba sports academy where she was
coached by her dad
and nicknamed mambasita she's very
competitive
vanessa posted this snap of capri
alongside the caption
quote capri repping our gigi hashtag
mambasita at the wnba all-star game
number two
kobe and vanessa's four-year-old
daughter bianca was also in attendance
sporting a mini version of her dad's
number 24 lakers jersey
the proud mama captioned the sweet shot
quote bb
repping daddy number eight number 24
wnba all-star game
back in 2018 kobe opened up to et
about coaching gianna's basketball team
after retiring from the nba
in 2016. it's been fun we've been
working together for a year and a half
and they've improved tremendously in
that time and
i got a group of great parents a group
of really really intelligent
hard-working girls
and you know they're all seventh graders
and they're all you know 12 years old
and
um but they've been playing so well i
play them up now so they play eighth and
ninth grade and
you know they've been winning
tournaments uh but the most important
thing is that they've been improving
they just keep getting better
and they love doing it you know they
love being around each other and while
gigi may have inherited her dad's skills
on the court
according to vanessa capri inherited his
looks
she has sweetly referred to the toddler
as daddy and gigi's twin
back in april she posted this snap to
instagram writing quote
it's the kobe stare for me